as part of a well-deserved victory lap
director bong joon ho
created a black and white version of
[Music]
parasite
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks to mubi for sponsoring this video
get your 30 day free trial at mubi.com
thomasflight in our modern era black and
white filmmaking kind of continues to
limp forward there's a handful of
releases
every year and occasionally a more
prominent release
recent examples include alfonso quran's
roma
the lighthouse from last year or mank
this year david fincher's new film
but even though it's rare these days
black and white is an important aspect
of filmmaking and film history to
examine some of the greatest films ever
made are in black and white
and even today it provides a different
visual palette for
filmmakers to work with so with this
parasite release it's an interesting
opportunity not just to see a modern
film in black and white but to be able
to compare
the color version against the black and
white version to see how it affects the
experience of watching the film
and what the strengths of each version
are it gave me a new perspective on
certain aspects of the story and i also
think the experience of watching it
suffers in a few ways i'll look at the
film in four sections how black and
white
emphasizes texture how it changes how we
perceive
light in the scene how it changes the
emotion and the context of
some scenes and finally the downsides
and how i think the experience suffers
from the shift to black and white
and talking about black and white
cinematography texture is often one of
the first things that comes up
and it's cliche only because it's true
shooting
in black and white really does emphasize
texture
it's not that you can't see the textures
in a color version of the film
but without color your eyes are drawn
to texture they tend to pop a lot more
on the screen i found that the textures
of the environments became a lot more
obvious the dirtiness and the complex
and cluttered
aspect of the poor family's house and
neighborhood
stood in much starker contrast to the
rich neighborhoods
cleanliness cleaner lines and more
simple environment
again when i point these things out you
can definitely see them in the color
version
but in watching the film the black and
white this contrast between the two
stood out more to me than it had in any
of the previous
times i watched the film and color
watching the color version i always
thought more about the differences in
amount and quality of light between the
two houses
and also the difference in openness of
space
but watching in black and white i think
the difference in cleanliness
precision of design and quality of
materials becomes more obvious
this emphasis on texture also made me
notice an aspect of the park family home
design that i hadn't noticed before the
textured concrete
walls that are used in some rooms the
way they have a sort of faux roughness
and the irony of that contrasted against
the actual
roughness of the concrete in the kim's
environment
became more apparent to me the emphasis
on texture has an interesting impact on
this scene where we descend
into the basement of the park home the
staircase in the black and white version
to me felt more like an
extension of the house instead of a
separate area the division between the
two spaces
feels less distinct and you can feel the
shift and texture
as things get dirtier and grimier during
the descent
into the basement some small details
stand out a bit more
for instance in this scene mr kemp's
face seems a little dirtier to me and
black and white
and i think the emphasis on the texture
of the scholar stone and the black and
white version
gives it a really interesting visual
quality that i don't think it has
in the color version in this shot the
harsh distinction between the sunlight
and the shadow
is more clear and i think it makes the
symbolism of mr kim crossing a line
a little bit more noticeable the
emphasis on texture adds some
interesting elements to the experience
of watching the film
but it's not necessarily a benefit
overall because you're also
losing any of the benefits you'd get
from the color in the film
which i'll talk about later perhaps the
most interesting and surprising thing to
me and the shift to black and white is
the way it affects how we perceive
light in the scene the contrast between
two different colors can help us
draw a distinction between two details
in a scene
even if they have the same tonal value
in black and white the distinction
between
every detail has to be defined by tonal
value so in a color scene you could have
two lines that are the same tonal value
but different colors
and your eye can tell them apart if you
shift to black and white and they have
the same
tonal value you won't be able to
distinguish between the two
because of this when you're shooting in
black and white or coloring in black and
white
you have to light or color the scenes
differently than you
would when using color in order to
maintain the same level of detail and
the same clarity in the scene
the upshot of this is that in the black
and white version of parasite there are
many scenes where
the darker elements of the scene have to
be brighter
so that we can see the details as
clearly as we can in the color version
as a result some of the scenes don't
feel as dark to me
in black and white as they do in color
this isn't really a big deal except in a
few crucial places
here the difference between the light
and dark areas of the scene
is actually important to the story and
selling the effect that the parks
can't see mr kim laying on the floor in
this shot in the black and white version
it doesn't feel like mr kim
is as much in darkness as he is in the
color version
not only is this area of the shot
actually
brighter in the black and white version
but in the color version we also get the
color contrast of the blue light from
the flashlight
mentally we tend to perceive blue light
as brighter than
warmer colors so the blueness of the
light here actually helps sell the
effect that mr kim is so in shadow that
the parks wouldn't notice him
i don't think it breaks the scene or the
film but it's a great example
of an effect that works really well in
color but isn't sold quite as well
in black and white i think parasite
suffers a little bit here because
it was shot in color if bong joon ho had
been working in black and white from the
start
he would have been able to shoot these
scenes in a way that would compensate
for any of the issues i'm talking about
here
black and white cinematography also has
the ability to alter the
emotion or feeling of certain scenes
it's hard to know exactly
how much of this effect is inherent to
black and white images
specifically and how much of this effect
just comes from the fact that we
tend to associate black and white images
with certain types of movies or a
certain period
in film history because as a viewer most
of the black and white movies you've
seen are probably a certain type of
older classic film with different
sensibilities
your brain is sort of subconsciously
attaching some of those sensibilities
and feelings that you're used to in
those kind of films
to anything else you see in black and
white the clearest example of this is
just how black and white films tend to
feel more
timeless and more classic simply because
most of the black and white films that
you've seen
are classics that have stood the test of
time watching parasite in black and
white
i think the film did feel more timeless
this effect
was undercut the most in scenes with
cell phones there's something about
seeing
a screen you almost always see in color
in black and white that creates a weird
sort of dissonance
overall i think the film felt less funny
to me in black and white but that could
come down just to the mood i was in this
time around watching the film
the most significant shift in the way a
scene felt to me
is the climactic action sequence
in black and white this felt more like a
battle or a conflict on some grander
scale maybe because it took on more of
the quality of like a western or
an older war movie previously this scene
had mostly seemed like
a chaotic scuffle with bursts of violent
action
rather than a war or a battle between
two forces
so watching the film in black and white
does add some new elements gives us a
different perspective on the film
but some things don't translate as well
and some things are lost
in the loss of color some compositions
and shots are more striking to me in
black and white than they are in color
but just as many don't work as well in
black and white as they did in color
for example the spectral highlights and
the blown out quality of the grass
in a scene like this just doesn't look
as good to me in black and white and it
seems kind of distracting whereas
in color i never really noticed it and
it didn't really bother me probably the
biggest thing that's lost in the
transition
is the emphasis of the greenery and
nature
that surrounds the rich family's house
the grass and the plants around the
house are so
vibrant saturated and green that really
stands in contrast
to the duller tones and the harsher
blues and oranges and yellows of the
kim's neighborhood and the area that
surrounds their house
the contrast of the pitiful little
smattering of
green weeds that are in front of the
kim's house against the
beautiful lush yard that's in front of
the park's house is
almost completely lost in the black and
white version the image of the rich
family on the grass during the party
kind of loses some of its pastoral
idealism that i think exists in the
color version
overall i think it's interesting to be
able to compare the two
and watch a film i've seen a bunch of
times in a different
format but i don't think the black and
white version benefits enough from the
changes to compensate for what's lost in
the transition
again a lot of this is probably due to
the fact that bong intended it as a
color film from the start so
if he had been shooting in black and
white from the start he would have
changed some things shot some things
differently to
work better with black and white if
you're a filmmaker even if you're not
interested in making a film in black and
white
studying what's different and the
benefits of black and white can help us
better understand the benefits and how
to use color filmmaking
i'm really glad bong jin ho decided to
make this version because seeing the
film from a different perspective
helps us learn more not just about the
film but about the differences
between color and black and white
filmmaking in general
if you got something out of this
breakdown please consider subscribing
and potentially becoming a patron and
finally i want to thank mubi for
sponsoring this video
if you want to dive deeper into the
world of black and white filmmaking
in mubi's library you can watch classic
black and white films like metropolis
nosferatu the general or battleship
potemkin or more recent black and white
efforts like
ida or the touring horse and many others
mubi is a hand curated online streaming
cinema where you can find
art house independent and foreign films
and that
space is almost exclusively where all
the black and white filmmaking takes
place these days i'm a big fan of mubi
it's my favorite place to discover
films that i wouldn't have even known
about otherwise you can try it now for
30 days and you'll have a chance to
check out their extensive library
or one of the new films that they add
every day
lubi is available all around the globe
for your extended 30-day free trial go
to
mubi.com thomasflight that's
movie.com thomasflight thanks again to
mubi for sponsoring this video
special thank you to my patrons for
their ongoing support five dollar
patrons have the opportunity to make me
watch a film
that i will make a special review video
about just for the patrons if you want
to get in on that fun
go to patreon.com thomasflight